[موسيقى]
ولد جاكسون بويل دون جزء من جمجمته
ودماغه يعاني الطفل من حاله نادره تسمى
مايكرو هادرا نين سفالي اخبرونا ان لدينا
اسبوعين معه ثم زادوا الفتره الى مده
شهرين لذلك كنا فقط نحضر انفسنا استعدادا
لفقدانه تقريبا كل الاطفال الذين يعانون
من حالته يموتون بعد ولادتهم بقليل ولكن
كلما مرت الاسابيع ومرت الاشهر ادركنا انه
كان متمسكا بالحياه بشكل جيد انه كان
سعيدا بالفعل كان في الواقع يعيش حياته
ومع كل يوم ازدادت قدرتنا على التحمل
وتشجعنا اكثر وكان لدينا المزيد من الامل
بسبب ما كان يقوم به احتفل جاكسون بعيد
ميلاده الاول في اغسطس اب الماضي ان حجمه
سيبقى ضئيلا في هذه المرحله ففي هذه
المرحله وهو يبلغ من العمر 13 شهرا يزن 5
كيلوغرامات لكنه بالتاكيد لا يعاني باي
شكل من الاشكال وحالته في الواقع لا تزال
تتحسن واحدى المشاكل التي يواجهها هي انه
غير قادر على تناول الطعام بنفسه لذلك في
كل يوم عليه استخدام انبوب التغذيه الذي
يصل مباشره الى معدته وهذا هو الشيء
الوحيد الذي يعتمد عليه في الواقع هو حقا
طفل عادي في الكثير من النواحي يبكي ويذهب
الى الحمام ويريد تغيير حفاضته وهو تقريبا
طفل مثالي علم الاطباء بوجود مشكله خلال
السابع عشر من الحمل كنا نؤمن بان الحمل
سيستمر وكنا نامل الا نفقده والان نحن هنا
اليوم وهو لا يبدي اي علامات بانه قد
يفارقنا هو كما ترون محبوب وعيناه لامعتان
وهو يستوعب اشياء كثيره وهو مدرك لما حوله
ونحن نعلم تماما الاعجاز بما يفعله وكذلك
واقع ما يمكن ان يحدث
غدا